quando a volte ci troviamo in un vicolo
cieco
quando l'ostacolo che abbiamo di fronte
a noi ci sembra più grande delle nostre
possibilità allora è saggio fare un
passo indietro e mettersi in discussione
il nostro problema nasce a delle radici
profonde e che vanno a minare il
rapporto fiduciario tra l'istituzione
indispensabile all'interno della
collettività e la comunità e la classe
dirigente del paese
le radici sarebbero profonde del
problema ma mi basta per far comprendere
arrivare un attimo a qualche decennio fa
il muro di berlino ha creato una
rivoluzione alla caduta del muro di
berlino in tutto il mondo quando noi
eravamo abituati a vedere
don camillo e peppone sembravano due
nemici che volevano sconfiggersi ma
eppure ognuno viveva dell'altro
eliminato uno crollava anche l'altro
infatti caduto il muro di berlino lascia
il problema tangentopoli
una rivoluzione infinita nel nostro
sistema e la comunità del paese viene
aggredita da un moto di sfiducia verso
quello che erano i simboli dello stato
perché si è sentita fortemente tradita
dai propri dalla classe dirigente del
paese e che chiaramente per proprietà
transitiva si è poi trasferita a tutti i
settori del pubblico di tutto ciò che è
istituzione e purtroppo l'incapacità
della classe dirigente del paese di
affrontare i problemi nelle sedi
istituzionalmente preposte a questo ha
fatto sì che molte volte fossimo
chiamati a sviluppare un'attività di
ammortizzatori sociali in natura le
molte volte la protesta si è scaricata
sulle piazze le tensioni sulle piazze ed
è chiaro che nasce un problema anche
perché noi da istituzione finiamola fine
per essere a
aggrediti sempre da quel moto di
sfiducia generalizzato è chiaro che gli
episodi sono 320 mila operatori nelle
varie forze di polizia
gli episodi sicuramente negativi sono
stati molteplici sono stati commessi
errori e per questo se accade se è
accaduto non chiediamo sconti ma
chiediamo di assumerci appieno tutte le
nostre responsabilità
nonostante questo nonostante questo moto
di sfiducia generalizzato rimangono
rimaniamo dall 80 per cento dei primi
anni 90 quindi ante quindi nella prima
repubblica
gli ultimi dati dell'anno scorso istat
ci dicono che le forze dell'ordine sono
al 73 per cento la prima istituzione
ancora che merita la fiducia dei
cittadini superiore al capo dello stato
65 è la chiesa cattolica
al 60 per cento quindi la flessione
tutto sommato è stata modesta però
invece è stata ed è calata in quello che
invece è uno dei punti importanti nella
classe nei punti nevralgici del nostro
sistema quindi chiaramente una parte
della classe dirigente del paese della
cultura del circuito mediatico e della
magistratura e questo ci pone in una
posizione veramente difficile siamo con
un dito puntato
e allora come fare soprattutto da parte
di chi è preposto a salvaguardare la
pacifica convivenza
e allora se questa è la nostra missione
istituzionale
siamo noi che dobbiamo metterci in
discussione e fare un passo indietro
fare un passo indietro e dire se
qualcuno deve essere messo sotto i raggi
ics quelli siamo noi ed è opportuno e
abbiamo lanciato questa campagna due
anni fa proprio l'abbiamo chiamata
verità e giustizia perché una giustizia
nasce solo da una verità ma la verità e
la giustizia senza anche un sentimento
disponibilità di carità rischiano di
essere la verità un blocco di marmo e la
giustizia una mannaia fretta faccio un
esempio banalissimo tra l'altro prima
ancora di entrare in polizia per far
comprendere cosa voglio dire era la
seconda volta che mio padre mi dava
l'auto quindi non sto parlando di eventi
tragici e andava a trovare la ragazza
amorosina feci un sorpasso azzardato ma
senza far rischiare su una nostra donna
era grandissimo la velocità di chi mi
stava davanti era bassa quindi mi fermò
una pattuglia di quelli che poi
sarebbero stati i miei futuri colleghi
una persona giovane mi viene è mi
contesta la contravvenzione
io lo guardo sconsolato gli dico solo
uno studente devo andare da mio padre è
la seconda volta che mi dà la macchina
non me la dà più lui si guarda un po in
giro e mi ridà patenti liberazione manda
via
e chiaro che se assunto una
responsabilità è un omissione atti
d'ufficio tra l'altro di run con il
lecce però questo vuol dire carità vuol
dire disponibilità non si può essere
eccessivamente rischi però chiaramente
bisogna partire su un terreno di verità
perché il nostro giudizio sul nostro
operato deve essere uno se è stato
giusto sbagliata questo comportamento
non se questo comportamento esisteva o
non esisteva dobbiamo ragionare sulla
verità e allora l'unico modo che noi
abbiamo pensato è stato proprio quello
di doverci mettere sotto i raggi ska con
lanciando una campagna per dotare tutti
gli operatori di videocamere in questo
caso noi abbiamo ore erano spy penn per
l'ingrasso ogni grado di video fanno
registrare proprio per certificare ogni
nostro respiro
quindi il problema non sarà più se è
successo o non è successo ma se quello
che è successo è un errore non è un
errore è opportuno non opportuno
questo è una valutazione che si deve
fare
aveva un grosso timore perché essere
messi sotto i raggi ics dà fastidio
tanti pensavo sarebbe stata una strada
in salita mentre invece una
soddisfazione grandissima mi è nata dall
ambiente interno dei miei colleghi che
si sono dimostrati altamente all'altezza
e
solo adeguati al ruolo perché è stata
una scivolata in discesa e stato proprio
una ovazione un un moto voglio dire
generalizzato in senso positivo
nell'accettare questo tipo di proposta e
la soddisfazione i dati ci danno mi è
nata anche dal fatto che nello stesso
momento una società più avanzata per
tutti il settore da quello molto volte
anche sociale economico tecnologico come
gli stati uniti avevano a los angeles ha
avuto la stessa idea 600 operatori erano
stati nel 2014 considerata della nostra
campagna nasce qui a bologna in piazza
maggiore nel novembre del 2013
siamo rimasti un mese in piazza facendo
finta di raccogliere contributi ma a noi
interessava parlare con la gente e
spiegare che la verità era un bene
fondamentale per tutti ed era importante
che un'istituzione come la nostra
potesse lavorare senza ombre in negli
stati uniti hanno fatto la
sperimentazione e si è dimostrato che
questa è una cosa bellissima
la 87,5 per cento degli episodi critici
tra le forze dell'ordine e l'utenza i
cittadini sono venuti meno un calo un
crollo una prevenzione straordinaria
questa è una grande cosa positiva e la
cosa ci ha veramente inorgoglito siamo
riusciti a ottenere un successo
grandissimo d'italia perché con la
nostra iniziativa abbiamo convinto la
nostra classe dirigente è il governo a
dover sperimentare nei reparti mobili
nei servizi di ordine pubblico ne sono
state comperate 200 perché era il numero
massimo come quantitativo economico per
acquistare a libero mercato
immediatamente senza fare un appalto le
procedure lunghe e farraginose per cui
40 50 torino milano roma e napoli nelle
parti mobili sperimentazione fatta sotto
il controllo del garante della privacy e
con il suo regolamento e la
sperimentazione si è conclusa
positivamente per cui è partito
l'appalto ma questo non ci è bastato e
abbiamo fatto pressione perché anche
sulle
volanti nei servizi di controllo del
territorio fosse approvato questa
sperimentazione e siamo riusciti ad
affare da raccogliere neanche questo è
un grandissimo risultato
ma questo non ci basta non ci basta
perché noi vogliamo le telecamere in
ogni ufficio di polizia perché noi
dobbiamo essere una teca di cristallo
non ci possono essere ombre sulla nostra
opera e siamo certi che riusciremo anche
in questo anche perché dove sono state
piazzate nelle celle di sicurezza
abbiamo avuto un crollo verticale del
100 per cento degli atti di
autolesionismo
e chiaro che nella necessità ognuno fa
quello che ritiene è quello di cui ha
necessità per aiutarsi quindi anche una
persona arrestata cerca di trasformare
l'operatore di polizia non imputato in
un procedimento connesso
per cui la sua parola non vale più da
pubblico ufficiale fino a prova
contraria ma è diciamo visto il
conflitto di interessi
vale come la sua quindi una strategia di
difesa però significa a volte farsi male
significa perdere tempo denaro e
attentare alla verità e la giustizia
e anche su questo penso che riusciremo
perché le nostre intenzioni sono le
migliori
chiudo perché proprio sintetizzando
quello che è lo spirito della nostra
iniziativa
andiamo noi essere strumento di
progresso
siamo qui alterne xte per questo non di
conservazione molte volte riteniamo la
legalità il rispetto della legalità
riteniamo la tutela dell'ordine e della
sicurezza pubblica come elementi per
preservare non è così non è così in
verità questi la legalità l'ordine la
sicurezza pubblica servono per
promuovere concordia e pacifica
convivenza che sono le vere le vere
fondamenta per un progresso materiale e
spirituale di una società grazie mille